what's up morning sir
good morning thank you for letting me
borrow your seller last night my nipples
are hard
very cold
I like it when you tell me that your
nipples are hard
and Isaac and barter knew something very
good say the first time I really have to
step in
No
I understand I really strong child gonna
try to blow my whistle
actually have the whistle over backpack
maybe you have a crazy boy
I never thought Isaac would ever ask for
something that you didn't know what it
was and you wanted to try it and he's
going to try some enoki mushrooms for
the first time mom the militia squad
came in sayonara
Barbie headed to we are inside the
fortress walls of the Osaka cabin we
could see it out in the distance oh cool
they make sure to look as old that she's
younger
all right on the boat we're going in
look at these ancient fixtures of Lights
and look at this ancient Lobby desk it's
ancient elevator built in the eighteen
look at this beauty right now in side of
Hansel
it's move therefore everybody be busy
worried about to do your bunch of
dressed up like samurais and take a
photo in front of the osaka castle did
you show them what what about you
check out the tofu veneer I forgot a
field socket cap what is that show me
what it's got me nice warden what do you
do with it ah
Oh transformation ninja time yeah we're
awesome right
we're ninja clothes you want to wear
Isaac
Luud here at the red ninja haha that's
sick you just want to buy him my little
ninja
hello little kitty store oh okay stand
on stage come on
hold on there's a long song thank you
sir okay OS is heavy pretty
Allen one favorite oh that's why it's
almost like a mochi but very light very
soft hot goodbye castle
alright relieve in Osaka going on a
bullet right and we're in the first
cards first car first class Osaka the
clouded Morocco Sokka hole 8 we are on
the train Gio is eating in the
background picking her nose I'm waving
Bart is also about to eat creeper
what are we doing I didn't hear what you
said but we are on a platoon and my hair
is all my stuff I've been traveling
shoot cute little souvenir / group
your food baby what is it thanks my
sushi I'm gonna open it sure June yep
she
I love how adorably like packaged
everything in like every single box even
if they know that you're gonna throw it
away like these packages I get to
present I've been reading and this is
actually their Ridge like the
traditional traditional way of eating
sushi like the actual do wrap it up like
this and it's all through she's meant to
be a fast food and on-the-go kind of
thing so this is as traditional as it
gets
bran to go it's wrapped in that thing
and I'm gonna eat sushi on the go I also
bought a taco flavored the Royals are
something long to Nepal melody and I was
in love with them I mean big tonalities
are they similar to the natural one
USA ketchup cheers brother
never talk black before the man is
trying pretty good it's way more than
the regular it's super dry way better
Cheers it's married life it's taken
effect forget that it's taking effect
you look just like nacho cheese let's
try it out
Oh since I've been in Japan I noticed
that they cater a lot of Mexicans are
not really cater but they have the
implement a lot of the Mexican culture
they have you guys in mind yes which is
pretty dope like for example it's
awesome I've seen a few Mexican
restaurants with like mixing of flags
everything they sell Coronas
a lot of the bars to the community are
afraid of a lot of Mexicans really care
to cool the Elite Eights on Taco Bell
yeah taco flavor
I'll be hiding the [ __ ] out Taco Bell or
what I know just like the og top of our
Bo Furi toes hint we need to bring them
to the stage anything else baby it's
what to warm it up and without it over
microwave Oh without anything like
walking is gonna get hot and they say to
wait for five minutes for it to be
cooked I'm so excited
yeah I can hear it
yes
check this out me hot more what do I do
here
you don't eat that thing that thing is
the heat pack down oh I [ __ ] up the
camera that's the science project there
I can't I'm not a lefty I don't know I
ended up pulling the camera my right
thank you for the help assist a loop and
slam dunk
I'll give you been hitting it off what
do you want to get spanked there we go
he was asking to be spanked for some
reason does what we're getting to like
you want to thank me are we doing
tonight tonight we are gathering the
entire group to have a sumo dinner it's
dinner where we get to see
Bart what do you know about sumo
wrestlers let's come to it but you know
that
now
such a sport that's why the three that
you see in the middle that's a very very
flamboyant embroider outfit actually
shiitakes so does these religious
rituals and if you like on the rise
I saw I bought it as a sumo wrestler you
do they're like a little business or
their wages on it's a very spiritual
sport and
very fast so they're like 300 or 500
pound like bus coming at you you're
drinking you blessed it would you ever
want her Restless if a wrestlers
yourself
Oh
[ __ ]
I was thinking JK everything can shake
it for the editor how do you got
and wait wait wing week